for the marlins jose uranya third start
this year coming off his first loss of
2020 has allowed six total runs in the
first inning in the two starts this year
now raffy devers has got a nine game hit
streak gonna spank that one down the
line into the corner that's a shot and
that lands right up against the bottom
of the fence he's got himself a long
single
as verdugo scampers into third so
already a challenge
for iranian
and uranium gets the strikeout there
goes to the slider for a big out number
one yeah well done home run last night
for south florida's own jd martinez one
and two now from urania and he gets him
chasing a slider as well back-to-back
strikeouts
and there are two away
pops this one up can wallow find it he
can and does how about that urania works
into and out of trouble in the first and
on the mound a former marlin nathan
avaldi making his eighth start this year
was the red sox opening day starter
first time that he did that in his
career so martin the scoring position
aguilar fanning and here comes joyce
round ball right to arroyo he's up and
over
and that retires the side no score after
one
there's jbj leading off the second
with that goes off urania ricochets to
the right side and chisholm able to make
the play and urania glove goes flying
not sure exactly where it got him or
what kind of pain he's in i think he's
all right because i think he you know
jackie bradley jr did not barrel that
ball up two down on two ground ball outs
quickly here in the second and miguel
rojas will move in there's the 0-1 of
the right-hand hitter and he swings and
hits it in the air to right field long
run for verdugo near the light slides
and makes a backhand catch for the out
he went a long way to get that ball not
hit all that high and made a fine play
in there for strike three he froze
aguilar is not happy with that but he
goes down admiring the pitch that's a
good pitch that's a split thinking
fastball right there from avaldi brian
anderson has not had success
historically against eval
here's the one two swing and a miss he
struck him out nasty splitter from the
baldi he's got it going that's his fifth
strikeout
one out gyro munoz a battery
and a miss that went down to one knee a
huge cut but that sinker's really
darting down and into these right hand
batters
here's the pitch swung on and missed and
dalbeck goes down on strike so
back-to-back strikeouts for routes two
and three in this inning
has been too sharp today another two
strikeouts he has six
first and third nobody out red sox had
this situation in the first and
squandered it jazz chisholm the second
baseman is 0-4-1
swing and a miss down he goes well he
muscled up to 97 for that one to put him
away
swung on and missed
and they held the runner at first base
and wallach strikes out for the second
time to corey dickerson with two outs in
the inning runners staying put and a
ground ball up the middle snagged by
xander bogarts from the outfield close
got him in first base
for round number three a bang bang play
very very close they may look at that
mattingly going for the challenge here
obviously dickerson is out marlins leave
a pair they make evaldi work
so martinez draws his second walk they
are all loaded up plucky will be the
hitter full count here it comes
live shot and a base hit into left field
one run is in here comes bogart sin to
score
and an absolute bullet by plawecki
that's his finest at bat of the season
puts the red sox in front two to nothing
that's a good call dave that that was a
great great at bat
the red sox up two to nothing have a
shot at moore here against quesada and
now rafael devers coming up
swinging a high fly ball this one driven
deep to right field it's way back there
and it is gone
rafael devers with number 11 a three-run
shot here in the seventh inning and he
just crushed it and the red sox lead it
five to nothing you gotta figure out a
way to rally here jorge alfaro connected
on a couple of home runs in last night's
ball game two on nobody out here in the
seventh
swings at the first one that is down the
right field line cooper rounding third
he's going to score on the third goes
miggy and it's a pinch hit rbi single
for jorge alfaro
the marlins break through so first and
third and now chad wallach
as wallach sends this one toward left
center field it is going to go off the
wall
miggy will score into second goes
wallach alfaro the third of the marlins
making noise in the seventh yes they are
starting to get uh get to this red sox
bullpen and wake the bats up
and a ground ball to devers at third
that will get a run home alfaro scores
to make it five to three
go to the ninth inning in a safe
situation for matt barnes the last
chance for miami is cory dickerson
fly ball center field jbj back to the
track and makes the catch and that does
it and the red sox have won two out of
three here in miami against the marlins